jo favorite was geht hier ist der reine
harter ich möchte von Dir wissen ob dir
schon mal bei einem Treffen mit der
richtig sexy Frau etwas total peinliches
passiert ist oder ist Dir überhaupt
irgendwas peinlich hau rein
ja Treffen mit einer Frau weiß ich nicht
genau ja ich treffe do nicht mit sexy
Frauen die Frauen die die Frauen die die
die die sich mit mir treffen die sind
nicht sexy um Gottes
Willen aber mir was passiert das ist mir
fällt mir jetzt gerade ein ich kenne
Kollegen die Kollegen von dem kennen
mich alle nicht hat eine große Party
gemacht in seinem Keller ich komme da
rein natürlich oh das FA und so erstmal
so Attraktion so dann komme ich da rein
trinken Schluck Alkohol verschluck mich
so krass dass ich auf einal anfange zu
kotzen und kotz in den ersten Z Minuten
und keiner kannte mich da außer dies
eine Typ den und ich sitze da und fang
sofort an zu kotzen al von einem Schluck
Alkohol weißt du ich bin FA so ich also
ich kann noch viel saufen er war mir so
peinlich Alter war echt g gar nicht klar
so das war echt in den letzten 10 Jahren
das einzige was mir wirklich peinlich
war so
Horror